Just like before, we substitute in our x-coordinate in the spot of x and our
y-coordinate in the spot of y, then we just simplify. For the left hand side, we
end up with 34. For the right hand side, we start out with 34, and there aren't
any variables involved in this expression. Since we don't have any place to
substitute anything in We can just say 34 is equal to 34. And again, looking at
these two sides and how they compare, 34 is still equal to 34. So, yes, these
two sides are equal. That means that we can say, that even though we may not
have any idea what this curve looks like, we know that this point lies on this
line. You might see some equations like this later on in the course. Get
excited.